[Music]
so
um this your first time in New York
should we be asking each other
that have you ever killed
anyone no no no not really really no
where do I
begin to tell the story of how great
love can be you're married the Sweet
Love St that is old Thana I should be
clear I'm not in this for the
[Music]
romance what is it that you two
do we're computer uh software
Engineers with very special things with
Ang songs with W I should be dead he
fills my
soul with so much love than anywhere
I how's the intimacy between the two of
you I'm scared could be
lonely I reach
for it's
there what do you think happens if we
fail our marriage our
mission and he you'll
be
[Music]
there